good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn how to get
great over to you Dean Grigio see the
biggest lie we've ever been told is to
work on our weaknesses biggest BS in the
world the hell with your weaknesses I
was in special reading till 12th grade I
couldn't spell for sure I right now my
computer if it could talk to me I try to
type words and send an email and I'll go
through like three different variations
you can't even find the word it's like
give up bro using a simpler word you
just don't have the vocabulary and I
know that but I still have multiple New
York Times bestsellers I've been touched
a lot been able to touch the lives of
millions of people because here's the
secret get great at what you're already
good at and pay people to do suck at
does that make sense get great at what
you're good I'm gonna give you one
example Ned Halliwell Oprah and America
considers them the number one a DD
specialist in the world attention
deficit disorder I said to him one day
we became good friends I said how do you
cure so many kids get him off riddle and
get him off medication he said simple he
said I find out what happens as
Johnnie's in class who's trying to read
a book his teacher says you sit there
and read that you can't get up until
you're done freaks out runs around now
he's got ADHD s hyper he said well we do
and then they medicate him because what
I do is I find what Johnny is good at
maybe he's good at math gym soccer and
we get his team around him his family
around him
and we help them get great at what he's
good at his confidence goes up and
Johnny reads the book on his own I don't
know why we're taught to focus on our
weaknesses so much the world belongs to
the people who are experts at what they
do and provide insane value not to the
person who is mediocre at everything
this is great story about the bunny that
forgot to hop and I forget who initially
told it but there's this bunny who's
going to school and he's learning to hop
and he's going to swim he gets an a on
his hopping but he's failing in the
swimming and so his parents
freaking out and said okay we've got to
take you to swim lessons you got to get
better at swimming you got to practice
you gotta hustle hard we're going to
pick you to private lessons I'm gonna
take you out to school you're going to
learn learn learn about how to swim and
slowly slowly slowly he gets better to
swim and he wasn't being an F student
swimming to a C student in swimming but
because he spend so much time being a C
student at swimming and bridging that
gap he also falls from being an A
student hopping to be a C stiffness
habit and kind of along the way he
forgets how to hop and that's what a
bunny is supposed to do it's hot and so
the world will tell you to focus on your
weaknesses they will tell you all the
things that you suck at and that you
need to get better at understand that
for you to have the impact that you want
to make the money that you want the
reach of people that you want to build
the business that you want the best way
to do it is to not focus on your
weaknesses it's to find the things that
you are great at find a thing that you
can be one of the best in the world app
you may not have that talent yet but you
have the ability to be one of the
greatest in the world at doing X what is
that thing
focus as much time on that thing as
possible and then as you build and grow
surround yourself with the people who
complement your weaknesses because they
love doing the things that you hate
that's how successful teams are built
that's what successful businesses are
built stop focusing on your weaknesses
so the question they today is I'm
curious what was the biggest weakness
that you gave up but people said you
needed to focus on but you felt like I'm
not going to do this anymore I have more
important bigger things that I'm more
talented at that I'm going to go and
crush instead what was that biggest
weakness that you gave up and hand it to
somebody else leave it down the comments
below really curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to
Alejandro Rivas Alejandro thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word it really really really
means a lot to me and I hope you're
enjoying the read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot
events beretta I wax spray choking me
you need to bet on your strength and
don't give a [ __ ] about where you suck
at you're going to way too many people
this room we're going to spend the next
30 40 years of their lives trying to
check the boxes other things that
they're not as good at and that you're
going to waste a lot of time and use I
highly recommend auditing yourself or if
you have no empathy or EQ or
self-awareness then find somebody in
your family or friendship that does and
let them tell you who you are and once
you believe that either for yourself or
someone else told you go directly all
chips all into that because that is the
only possible way in my opinion watching
from the outside that is let me rephrase
that is a very highly likely way of
over-indexing because the truth is if
you want to be an anomaly you've got to
act like one you know like and so that's
it that's what I got so thanks for
having me you need to know what your
unique strengths are and be willing to
delegate so I would say that the
question of whether you should take a
skill learn it yourself delegated
someone else or hire new team member are
determined by having a very accurate
self assessment and assessment number
your team skills not only what you can
do but what you should be doing that's
very important so if you're a start-up
CEO or founder and you have a team of
say two to ten people as soon as you
have fun
hire you should not be focused on the
things that you're a badass sounds very
very intuitive but it's not because you
might have enough time to do those
things but the question is do you have
the attention to dedicate to this thing
so they're not an interruption
especially if you're a venture back
startup and you're competing as other
companies that also have a lot of
funding the game the game and the race
goes to the Swift so you have to have
you have to have a lot of velocity
knowing your strengths and weaknesses
and knowing what you enjoy doing you
know if you look at it as a job you've
already lost it it's not going to be
your passion and you're going to count
the hours if you look at it as something
you love to do um and then you know what
your strengths are then you can leverage
those strengths in your business and in
helping others and once you recognize
your weaknesses then you can work with
people that complement you I mean every
one of my businesses I've had a partner
who's very anal Martin Woodall Todd
Wagner are incredibly anal people
perfectionist because I'm a slob you
know I'm a big-picture think about
what's around the corner how is
technology going to change things how
can I change you know this industry and
you know making sure that there's
somebody there to make to dot the i's
cross the t's and keep me in the bass
lines Elm and you know recognizing my
weaknesses is just as important as
recognizing my strengths my core
competencies and and you know having a
passion to do